[Music]  remember me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Miguel Natalia la parka de and gaël  Garcia Bernal perform a stunning  rendition of Coco's remember me during  the 2018 Oscars I heard that you're a  little nervous about tonight  yeah I don't even thanks for reminding  me I was already like laughing and I  heard you were to take a shot of tequila  oh I will I will I will I haven't done  and I think or maybe I have but they  don't feel it so it's like if I hadn't  had it you know maybe that's it you did  it and you don't remember well that's  the thing that's there that's what  happens when you're very nervous yeah  like five five shots of tequila stone  don't they just don't operate but then  when you're singing maybe maybe the  girls a little nervous  have you talked to him what he's not a  singer so you need to have you know some  to get in the Oscars and sing a song but  he's amazing I think he's an amazing  actor and he he's gonna do great